these Red Sox the greatest rivalry in
sports I do think so when both teams are
good and not in last place
watching Derek Jeter's last at-bat here
against the Orioles classic base hit the
right field walk-off hit
I'm not making a piece Michelle here to
come to the Yankees I want to show you
to go to the best place where he can you
know Thrive and be the superstar that he
needs to be
Chinese
I just think the coolest thing for me is
the roll call every year doing the roll
call watching before the game always
wanted to be a part of that but as a
starting pitcher you never are but the
roll call is the coolest thing about
Yankee Stadium